account is stable enough that we should
think about
starting if you're ready to go yep
so again this is the next installation
of the beyond satisfiability workshop
or seminar series or whatever it is and
um we
usually don't spend too much time
introducing the speakers because we want
to give them
time to talk instead and the setup i
think today
is uh like a first
roughly one hour seminar uh and then
we'll have a break
and then we can have a deep dive into
exciting technical stuff
for those who wish to stay along for a
second half
i'll say just a few words about the
speaker though kiran makrish from
university of glasgow so kieran is one
of these people
i have come to know one of these
practitioners who is very very
disrespectful of theoreticians
because here we are you know proving
that
problems like clique and subgraph
isomorphism would have you
supposedly exponentially hard but
kieran insists on having this amazing
solver the glasgow
subgraph solver that actually solves all
these and many other even harder
problems
um shockingly efficiently and uh
i think part of the plan today is maybe
he'll tell us some of his secrets how
he's actually doing all of this
but i'll i guess i won't speculate i'll
just leave the floor to kieran
and he'll tell us thank you
so uh this talk is mostly going to be
about
cliques so the maximum clique problem is
you're given a graph like this
and you want to find a set of vertices
where every vertex in the set is
adjacent to every other vertex in the
set
and you're looking to find as bigger
clique as possible so this is
um a group of people who are all friends
of each other
and in this particular graph you've got
four is the biggest clique like that
just going to start with a bit of
ancient history uh from 1992.
i was uh not around for this i was alive
at the time
um so i i don't entirely know how much
impact this had but um for the clique
community the
the second dmx implementation challenge
in 1992 was
where everything started
this was an organized competition
featuring
three problems maximum clique graph
coloring and satisfiability
um i don't know how much
effect this has had on the sad community
either
i get the impression that this is at
least partially where things started out
and the goal of the challenge was um
let me say it was recent advances in
complexity theory have shown in the
worst case sense
these problems are not only hard to
solve or how to approximate but
our goal in this challenge is to find
out how hard they are in practice
so what did the demx implementation
challenge give us well first of all it
gave us
a file format for benchmark instances
and if you've worked with sat solvers
this probably looks reasonably familiar
the challenge to find a
format for cnf which is still used today
and it defines a file format for graph
problems as well
so the way we read this is um the first
line is a header line
it's saying this is a graph problem
the 12 on the first line is uh
v number of vertices these are indexed
from
one and the second line the second
number is the number
of edges then every subsequent line in
the
input is saying for example there is an
edge from vertex one to two versus an
edge from vertex
one to five and so on uh
the first thing immediately comes to
mind when looking at the format is
um this this edge number is
uh a bit ambiguous
the file format can sometimes have edges
in both directions so if you say for
example that
one is adjacent to two you can say that
two is adjacent to one
but you don't have to sometimes it
matters if people specify directed
graphs the dimx format is reused
this number 25 can either tell you the
number of edge lines in the file or it
can tell you the number of edges
it is it is very ambiguous
uh in a lot of the input files including
some of the ones in the
original dmx challenge the number is
just wrong well
this is something to bear in mind
this file format has stuck with us and
it is still in use too
to this day it also gave us a set of
benchmark instances
which which come from various families
there are random graphs which have
various sizes various densities and
they're created using various different
models
uh not just they're just rainy random
graphs but
uh for example graph uh random graphs
which have a very large degree spread
uh so in a in a simple model of a random
graph every vertex has roughly the same
degree
but there are ways of generating graphs
of different models
a lot of the benchmark instances were
from an early attempt to cryptography
application so these are graphs where
there is a
very large clique hidden inside what
appears to be a random graph
where you'd expect to find a much
smaller clique
the aim here was in some sense you could
prove who you are because you are the
only person who can find this really
big clique in a graph
it's it turns out this application
completely
hasn't worked in practice um as
as we'll see later on finding these
large hidden clicks is actually pretty
easy these days
but it was interesting to see what
people were thinking in those days
there are a set of graphs from fault
diagnosis applications so a real world
application
there are some graphs from coding theory
called hamming and johnson graphs and
there are graphs corresponding to
various mathematical
conjectures including the keller problem
which i think some people in the sac
community know a lot about
and finding steiner triples and
they also gave us an experimental
protocol which is
this is how you should evaluate your
maximum quick solver
and what they do is they distribute a
small maximum clique solver
and they tell you what you should do is
compile it and run it on these five
problem instances and
report your runtimes then what we do is
they have a
standard piece of hardware which was an
sdi challenge machine
and again they report the runtimes on
this machine
and what we told people to do was to
scale their results
based upon their performance relative to
the performance on this machine
so if you run the benchmark algorithm
twice as fast as their reported runtimes
then they tell you that you should uh
let's see you're twice as fast you want
to multiply all your runtimes by two
when announcing your results this was
considered a standard experimental
protocol for a long time
interesting to see we can still do this
today we can still download and run the
original cleat solver solvent was
distributed uh it was written in
very old school c so it does not
make a modern c compiler happy we get a
lot of compiler warnings
um strictly speaking some of these
things that are doing it
or undefined behavior at runtime we can
run this
we saw previously we saw
179 seconds it's the reference time for
the hardest instance
on modern hardware just on my laptop we
are down to
uh just four seconds for running this
and in comparison a modern cleap solver
on the same instance
is is running in 0.7 of a second
so this gives you an idea of how much
we've gained from hardware versus how
much we've gained from software on these
instances
this is not entirely a fair comparison
this benchmark instance is a 500 vertex
random graph of density 0.5
and i guess at this point we all know
that benchmarking just like random
instances is a bit dodgy
um modern quicksolvers are a lot better
on structured graphs and only a little
bit better
on random graphs
so i would say we have gained more than
a factor of 7 improvement
since 1992
but of course this rescaling thing um
i'm
i'm hoping everybody is thinking okay
this is a terrible idea it's a good
thing we've moved on from this and we
don't do it anymore
i i did some work where i demonstrated
that by
rescaling results you could basically
prove any algorithm was faster than any
other
unfortunately rescaling was still
standard in the
cle community about points
people would even take their own results
from earlier papers and rescale them
uh presumably because they'd lost their
own source code
so i'd like to say if i'm glad that the
dmx community have put this behind them
unfortunately they still do this the
current dmx implementation challenge
owing to how to look is on
vehicle routing problems uh and they
they do something very strange by using
cpu mark and rescaling
they are the dimex community is still
opposed to
making people publish by source code and
share vessels could and running
experiments on standard hardware
uh i think this is something that the
sat competition does
an awful lot better in that respect
so start by giving a quick overview of
maximum click algorithms this
is is going to leave out a lot of stuff
um
there are several papers a year on
quicksolvers so
not as many as uh sat for example but
this is
is still a fair amount of work
so i'm going to omit a lot of stuff if
you are
looking for more details there's a
survey by prosser in
2012 which covers a lot of the history
and then my phd thesis has some more
recent material in it
but just to give you an idea of how
these algorithms work
a typical maximum click algorithm works
by
growing candidate maximum clicks so
at any stage we have a candidate maximum
click which we will call
a and we have a set of candidate
vertices
p p is
the set of vertices which individually
you can add in
to the maximum clique so the invariant
is that at any given time
every vertex in p is adjacent
to every single vertex in a
and when you start off the algorithm the
set a is empty and p is every vertex
the idea is you're you're growing this a
set and shrinking this pset as you go
along
so you pick some vertex v and you branch
so either v is present in a maximum
clique
in which case you create a new p prime
set
which is just a set of vertices in p
that are still adjacent to v so you're
throwing everything out
that cannot be added to a clique anymore
this this is like unit propagation
insert
and then we make a recursive call
finding a maximum clique
in a new a which is a with a branching
vertex v added in
and this reduced pset or alternatively
v is not at the maximum clique so we
throw it out of p
we pick another v and we keep going
and then the trick here is we also have
a bound function
so we keep track of the largest quake
cell
found so far which we call the incumbent
and if at any given point and this c
should be an a if at any given point
the size of the clique that we have so
far
plus the number of vertices that we
could potentially add to it
is less than or equal to the largest
glute found so far we don't need to keep
going
we can backtrack immediately so this is
the
simplest framework for a gleek algorithm
and then then we start getting clever so
um an early example was degree filtering
so the degree of a vertex is just the
number of things
that are adjacent to it and
every vertex in a quake and size omega
has to have degree at least
omega minus one so it's going to be
adjacent to at least everything else in
the clique
so at any given point if you have any
vertices that are of sufficiently low
degree you can just throw them out to
lose them completely and you don't need
to worry about them again
and you can calculate this degree either
in the original graph or you can
calculate a dynamic degree
just looking at what is present in
the vertices you've taken so far in the
vertices you haven't thrown out
and this lets you prune the search base
a lot in some cases
here's something even cleverer uh let's
take a graph and let's color in the
vertices
so adjacent vertices have to be given
different colors
and in this case so i've colored
vertices one three and seven
in blue vertices two four and nine in
green five six and ten in yellow
and eight eleven and twelve in pink
and if you think about it uh
because i've used four colors here there
cannot possibly be
a clique with more than four vertices in
it
so every vertex in a clique has to be
given a different color
it could be that the gap between the
clique and the coloring number is large
so
if if i find a 10 coloring that does not
necessarily mean there's a 10 vertex
clique but it does mean there isn't
an 11 vertex clique
and additionally every
vertex the clique has to belong to a
different color class so
algorithms will exploit this information
of course producing a coloring is also
np hard
and in practice coloring is even harder
than cliques so we don't want to be
producing very expensive coloring but we
could do a
greedy coloring very very quickly
and a large part of the uh
difference between how different greek
songs work between about 2004 and 2012
was different ways of producing this
color bound
as quickly as possible so this is
typically something we do at every stage
of the search tree
we produce a new coloring just looking
at the remaining vertices
in the p set so this this coloring
really has to be fast
i'm not going to go into all the clever
tricks people have come up with to
produce better colorings
but if you uh pull up a list of
publications by
etsuji tamita uh you'll get a pretty
good overview of
all the research in this area and it's
an interesting fact that the color bound
is
strictly better than the degree bound
for any reasonable
any reasonable greedy coloring if you
think about it
a vertex of degree d
can't be put in a color class
greater than d minus one
because it has to be adjacent to
something in every previous color class
um
an additional you can show that it has
to be adjacent to a lot of high degree
vertices before it itself ends up in a
later color class
and once you've recognized this you can
take degree filtering out of the
algorithms and just use the color band
instead which is
much simpler
and one of the key reasons we're able to
produce
these colorings so very quickly now is
bit parallelism
we can do adjacency filtering so the
equivalent of unit propagation in a sat
solver
in just a couple of clock cycles it's
it's an intersect with complement
operation on a bit set
modern hardware can work on 512 bits or
more
per clock cycle so propagation is
extremely fast
and the same as of coloring there are
special greedy
bit parallel coloring algorithms and
it's reached a point that
um we could do over a million
recursive calls per second on these
algorithms on say a 512th
vertex graph
there are more details on this on papers
by pablo sansegundo
if you want to see the the history of
how big parallelism came to be
in greek solving
there's also been some work on thread
parallelism um
unlike for sat we do know how to
parallelize quick algorithms
um we can get average speedups of around
28 on a 32 coil machine but there is
very high variance between
different instances it's particularly
interesting that large
super linear speedups are extremely
common
so you can get speed up of a million or
a billion
out of a 32 core processor
and this this happens fairly regularly i
can
discuss this in more detail later on if
people are interested in what's going on
uh but the short version is if we could
put restarts
into a clique solver efficiently then
this would go away but we
can't so what we do is we design
parallelism to
introduce diversity into the search
instead
and one of the main features of uh
clique algorithms gain up to about
2012 which is still used in elders uh
after this is colour ordering
so it's fairly well known in branch of
belvedere griffins for the
order used for branching is vitally
important
so which vertex do we pick to branch on
what cliques always do is something a
bit interesting this is a technique
introduced refined by tamita
and his co-authors so we've produced a
greedy coloring
in the graph i've shown let's let's say
we color vertices
in uh numerical order so i'll kill the
vertex 1 first
it gets the color blue that stops me
from coloring vertex 2 in blue
but i can color vertex 3 in blue and
then vertex 7 in blue
what i do is as i write out colors as as
i kill the vertices i write these out
so i write down for them coloring vertex
1
then vertex 3 then vertex 7 and
i'm using color number 1 to do so
if i go back and say what can i kill the
next and i can color vertex
2 4 and 9 in green
then 5 6 and 10 in
yellow using color number 3 and
8 11 and 12 in purple using cone number
four
and now what click algorithms do is
they'll branch
on the rightmost vertex in the rightmost
color class
so they will start by branching on
vertex 12
there when they backtrack
they will branch on the second last
vertex in the last color class
so branch of vertex 11 and then on
vertex
8. eight and we know for
each of these three vertices of the
bound functions of
the maximum contribution we can have
from the colored vertices is four
and then we've emptied this color class
so the next vertex we branch on
is vertex 10 and now we see that the
band has dropped to three
well this might be enough for we can
abandon search if not we keep going we
would branch
on six and five
and then we branch on nine uh with the
color band dropping
once again and so on until we until the
band kicks in
um so we
a lot of solvers use this right to left
bordering
and it's interesting to look at why they
do this
there's a claim by tamita who introduced
this
that vertices in the right most color
classes
are generally expected to have a high
probability of belonging to a
maximum clique so i'll talk you through
an argument
so for a vertex to end up in the
rightmost color class
it has to have a high degree and it has
to be
adjacent to a lot of high degree
vertices
you could you can prove this property of
greedy colorings
and the belief is that vertices of high
degree that are adjacent to
a a lot of high degree vertices
themselves
are very likely to appear in a clique
compared to other vertices
then the argument is the faster
a maximum quick algorithm can find a big
clique
the faster it will run uh the more of
the search base it'll be able to print
so this is a very nice argument it's
repeated in several places
a lot of people use this color ordering
and indeed you can you can easily verify
if you iterate from left to right you
can rejig the bound function slightly
and the
algorithms run several orders of
magnitude slower
but there's a problem this claim is
completely untrue and it's fairly easy
to test this
but nobody had thought of doing this
but what you can do is you can take the
algorithm you can take your favorite
click algorithm and you can tell it
oh okay you're allowed to assume that
there is a
large maximum click already so you can
initialize the algorithm of a large
incumbent
and run it again so all the algorithm is
doing is producing
a proof of optimality that there is no
logic leak
so in this case time to find an optimal
solution should not make any difference
um so left to right and right to left
color ordering should be
exactly the same right and this really
isn't the case you still have the
several orders of magnitude speed
difference if you iterate right to left
versus left
to right even if all the algorithm is
ever doing is proving optimality
um so i
i don't know why nobody had thought to
test this
it is a relatively easy thing to do
what's even more interesting is that as
clique algorithms get better
they are getting worse and worse anytime
behavior and they are
finding they're taking longer and longer
to find a strong incumbent
so um modern clique solvers will not
find the optimal solution until very
near the end of the search process
and yet they still perform better than
quicksolvers would find a good solution
early
so there's something interesting going
on here that's uh
i will talk about this in part two of
the talk and explain what's really going
on
if if you're interested
so people have spotted that finding a
good optimal solution quickly
is important so one thing
some solvers do know is they run local
search before starting a main algorithm
to get a good initial incumbent
a pet peeve of mine is that
the way this is done is not necessarily
in a principled manner
so a recent publication that did this
said okay
uh we will run a hundred thousand
iterations of a local search heuristic
before we start my main algorithm
except for these two problem instances
because we know these are difficult
instances so we'll run these for
60 million scans instead
and it just so happens that this 60
million number is pretty much
exactly how many times you need to run
the heuristic to
find the optimal solution for these two
instances
whereas the hundred thousand scans is
enough to find an optimal solution for
every other instance in the benchmark
sets
i am curious as to have a slip past a
reviewer let's
let's just leave it about
so what are people doing on click
algorithms these days oh
one thing is trying to produce a
stronger bound
one way of doing this is to produce a
better greedy coloring so you can
for example color vertices in a
different order or you can look at a
coloring and you can
tinker with it slightly to try to
produce a better coloring
another approach is to try to produce a
bound that behaves better than coloring
there are two approaches to this one is
something called a fractional coloring
where you give each vertex
two colors uh this produces
tighter bounds for the coloring but it's
more computationally expensive
then there are also bounds inspired by
max sut
i will just go over briefly because i
think this might be of interest to
a few people so you could solve the
maximum creep problem as a maxsac
problem
you'd have a variable for every vertex
and
one means that this vertex is present in
the gleek
you have hard clauses for every non-edge
so for example if vertex 2 and 3 are
non-adjacent
then you would say you can't take both 2
and 3.
and in a naive encoding you would have a
soft cause for each vertex and you want
to maximize the number of soft clauses
that you satisfy
a better encoding is to have a soft cl
for each color class so for example if
x1 and x3 or x7
are in the red color class uh you have a
soft chord saying
pick x1 or x3 or x7
this approach using max silvers is not
competitive for either two or three
reasons
first unit propagation is just way too
slow compared to what clique solvers are
doing
and second you really need to use
dynamic colorings to get this effect so
you don't want to be coloring the entire
graph once
you want to be coloring just the
residual vertices you want to be doing
this at every stage of the search
i believe but can't entirely prove
conclusively that
the maxsat approach is also not
competitive because uh
what learned clauses don't get reused
very much
i think there are some interesting
questions on
uh why clause learning in graph
algorithms doesn't seem to do very much
however we can steal a max at conflict
analysis algorithm and put it into
a coloring algorithm this could do some
interesting things it can identify for
example the er three different mechanic
vertices that don't form a triangle
so there's been quite a lot of work on
how you steal the maxat algorithm and
put it into a quicksolver and get good
results in these
recent papers by pablo sansegundo and
chilean
lee go into this in quite a lot of
detail if if you're interested further
uh and a pet topic of mine is
uh pre-flogging so
oh i did some experiments where i
ran quicksolvers on billions of problem
instances
and ran into something very annoying
every other person's quicksolver that i
ran would disagree on what the solution
is in
say one in ten thousand instances
something like that
the as far as i can see um
all the solvers that you might
reasonably currently claim to be
state of the art will occasionally
produce an incorrect answer
on a quick instance
this this is particularly annoying
because clique solvers are being used as
a component inside of the solvers
uh so for example the um the pace
challenge for those of you who work in
parameterized complexity was
i believe one a few years ago by uh
an algorithm that uses uh a buggy clique
solver as its main component
so this is this is a bit irritating um
we know from the sat competition to
proof logging is
a really good way of catching these
buggy solvers
so even if a soldier appears to be
producing the right answer
if it's producing its right answer by
spurious means
then this will be detected
but there are a couple of problems with
uh
just taking the sat proof looking
approach and introducing it to greek
solvers
the first is it clicks always just runs
so much faster than start solvers so
the overhead of writing to a disk
suddenly becomes really really
significant
compared to what sounds always do the
other problem is
we have all these bound functions that
involve strong reasoning
and it is really not clear
how to write these um the reasoning
carried out by these bound function
downs in
a direct proof
it is still possible to do proof looking
for quicksolvers and again i'll discuss
this in
part two of the talk the way we do this
is to switch to using cutting points
proofs
it turns out that cutting points proofs
can very compactly express
all of the reasoning carried out by as
far as we can see every glee cal griffin
has ever been proposed but i will i will
talk more about that later if people are
interested
okay what about the problem instances
again the sac community has
the competitions which have new sets of
instances all the time
um in contrast for clique
people are still reusing the gimmick the
original set of dimx instances for
most experimental papers this is
this is interesting for a few reasons um
what is a lot of these dmx instances are
of the
large hidden solution variety and a lot
of remainder are
random instances so these
are potentially not typical instances
for what people
really want to use for solver for and
this really biases solver design
now in particular the large hidden
solution instances
if you can find the large hidden
solution then
the proof of optimality is trivial for
any reasonable algorithm
so um this shows why for example people
put a huge amount of effort into
running local search before they start a
quick algorithm
it just so happens that a property of a
lot of the dimx instances
is once you've found an optimal solution
proving it is dead easy
this is not the case for more typical
application instances
in fact all of the application instances
in the original dmx set
are computationally very trivial for any
kind of naive solver
there are a few open instances left from
the mathematical conjectures and random
graphs
categories are not a few more in this
category that can only be solved
by many cpu years of time by large
parallel algorithms
but there are sufficiently few hard
instances left
that for example permuting the input
graphs can make a huge change to what
uh people consider the state-of-the-art
to be
this is particularly the case on the
large shipping clique instances if you
if you just re-label the vertices in the
graph you can
again effectively show for any technique
you like is a good technique or a bad
technique
but this isn't widely recognized to be
de max instances are still widely used
in publications it's
it's standard to publish a table of
results of
all of the dmx instances and to claim
that you're better on two or three of
the hard instances you have a better
algorithm
i think this is a shame
people also experiment on random
instances a lot
here is uh some plots from the
literature showing
what happens in random graphs for
solving cliques now
we're looking at number of recursive
calls here for some different algorithm
variants
are as we vary the edge probability and
have a fixed number of vertices so on
the left 100 vertices in the right 150
vertices
so on the left running from an edge
probability of 0.4
up to 1 and on the right from 0.5 up to
0.95
and you can see that okay for some
reason
the density of approximately 0.88 0.9 is
hardest for maximum greek solvers
but we didn't really know much more than
that
in 2012
one of the things i did was to rerun
this kind of experiment but using
a a much higher sample size a much
smaller density step what happens is
you get something like this so looking
at
either a 50 a 100 or a 150 vertex graph
uh every edge appears uniformly at
random
with some probability between zero and
one which changes on the x-axis
and we look at one particular solver and
i'm just measuring number of recursive
calls
to find a solution as as an approximate
value of runtime
bearing in mind here 10 to the sixth
recursive calls is
under a second oh so these are
relatively easy instances when we see
this curve we see uh
the hardest density is uh somewhere
around 0.9
it looks like uh if you if you try to
connect
the highest uh the highest difficulty
it looks like that for slightly larger
graphs
the density which is hardest
increases slightly oh it would be
it'd be interesting to know there's a
theoretical justification for this it'd
be interesting to know if
uh there is a theoretical reason that
a particular density is the hardest for
maximum clique
the impression i get from listening to
theory talks is
people believe that the 0.5 region
should be the hardest for clique solvers
which
doesn't seem to be the case in practice
another interesting thing you can see on
this part if you zoom in
oh is i don't know how well this is
showing up on the slides but
does this line look straight or does
this line look wiggly
if i put a straight line through you can
see that oh
this this curve we have it looks like it
might be
you know a skewed normal distribution
something really isn't it's
it's its own very peculiar shape
and i again i will talk about this in
part two of a talk if you're interested
to see where this shape comes from
what we can say about random instances
well there's a lot of interesting stuff
going on here
uh moving on slightly so people also
like to run experiments on
large sparse crafts the
biggest demax graph has four thousand
vertices in a density of 0.5 it's
it's a random graph this will fit in an
adjacency matrix
on modern hardware this this is
certainly not a big graph
by big data standards and a lot of
papers claim that
large sparse graphs are more realistic
in some sense so
it was this claim was never entirely
clear to me
um it is certainly the case that
every large graph we have is sparse
but this could just be because we can't
fit large dense graphs on disks so
people don't collect them people do
experiment on
collections of large bus graphs for
example from
the network repository it's not
immediately clear to me why anyone would
want to find a clique in a road network
but this is the sort of thing people do
so there is a whole other family of
algorithms that run on
little finding a maximum clicking large
bus graphs
the difficulty here is mainly you can't
fit everything in memory
and you can't do anything that is more
complicated than linear time or
say log linear maybe so
these algorithms are all about using
sneaky data structures and about
replacing the
color with something that's much faster
to compute but a weaker bound
i'll i'll not go into any more detail on
either
so that there's an interesting question
if the instances that we
benchmark on are so terrible does
anybody actually care about quicksolvers
in practice
so we know that sat over are used all
over the place
is it the case that clique is just a
niche application that isn't as
interesting a practice
uh and it says that no um
there are a lot of clique papers that
appear in places like the
journal of chemical and informational
modeling which might seem a bit strange
it turns out that chemists really really
want to solve
clique problems in fact what they really
want to do is solve maximum comments of
graph problems
so the maximum common subgraph problem
is you're given
two graphs which i've drawn here on the
left and the right
and you want to find what do these two
graphs have in common so give me the
biggest subgraph that you could find
in both graphs and here
we can see we have these two separate
components so we have the
we can find all but one vertex in common
between these two graphs
and the way you solve this problem in
practice is by a reduction to the creek
problem
i won't go over this reduction in
all its gory details but the the basic
idea is
um you
you're constructing a partial mapping
between your two input graphs which i
have on the left
uh so the idea is for example okay i'm
going to map
b to one i'm going to map c to two and
i'm going to map
d to 4. what you do is
for every vertex in the first graph
you create a set of quick vertices
and the vertices in this set are
vertices in the second graph
so here we have four vertices in the
first graph four vertices in the second
graph
so we would be creating a set of 16
vertices in
what we call an association graph except
that it's a rule that you can't map a
vertex with a loop to a vertex without a
loop or vice versa so these vertices are
deleted
and a clique in this association graph
corresponds to an assignment uh between
the
uh the two input graphs so
what we can see here is we have this
we have this three vertex clique
and we're saying that if you map b to
one and
c to two and d to four
uh you're finding a three vertex maximum
common subgraph
and variations on this encoding uh let
you do a lot of
similarity comparisons between graphs
and it turns out that this
this really is the application where
tweaks are used in practice
chemists really really care about this
sort of thing
but we don't have very many yes so
question
here since you have an edge also
like between the orange and the blue guy
so you
you won't have an induced subgraph here
is that right
uh novice so this is this is maximum
common induced so um
in the in the two input graphs uh
orange is not adjacent to blue and
orange is not adjacent to blue
so in the clique we have we have this
edge between orange and blue
because the adjacency of b to d
is equal to the adjacency of one to four
does that make sense so we have
um we have an edge in the clique graph
if we can assign two vertices
simultaneously
so if they are both adjacent or they're
both non-adjacent
in the inputs
does does that make sense
i think so i was just pointing out that
like you you want when you're taking
this maximum
thing yet you want it to be induced
because otherwise you could take a very
boring sub graph without any edges yes
so there is a variant called the maximum
common edge
subgraph problem which is
is the non-induced equivalent the issue
is if you're trying to maximize if
you're trying to find a non-induced
common subgraph
the question is why don't you take all
of the vertices and none of the edges
so if you want non-induced you need a
different objective function as well
yes so it's it turns out this is used a
lot in practice not just for finding
common
subgraphs but for finding common
substructures for variations on this
encoding
but we don't have very many of these
problem instances despite this being
where neil cleatholds are run
i i believe one of the difficulties is
there are
commercial applications of this so
people sell clique solvers which consist
of
something which reads in a standard
chemical information database file
format
does this encoding and produces some
nice outputs
so they're not really very keen on
sharing the tools that convert
chemical graphs into the inputs that
people want to actually run on
there are at least a couple of people
who
fund their research by selling
quicksolvers to chemists unfortunately
another problem here is that it turns
out that chemists don't actually want to
solve
maximum common subgraph a lot of the
time
if you showed this maximum common
subgraph
to a chemist they would probably say
no that's wrong that isn't one graph
that's two graphs
so um a lot of chemists seem to believe
that a graph has to be connected and if
it isn't connected then it is two graphs
so they would say that you couldn't find
this
and this because they're not connected
so i'm not finding it connected uh
a common subgraph at all what we
actually want you to find is this
uh this is a the maximum common
connectors and graph this is as big as
you can get
uh if you have to find it connected to
graphics one vertex smaller
now there's an interesting question of
how you solve this whether you can do
this by reduction to clique or not
you can't easily reduce this to a gleek
problem in a nice elegant way
but what you can do is hack a quick
solver so that it understands that it is
finding
a maximum common connect it's a graph
this this is in some ways clique solving
modular theories
uh except it is far less elegant in
practice
you really have to muck around a vienna
to the cleat solder if you want to
if you want to solve a connected problem
but it is a fun one to play around with
uh there are also variants on the clique
problem that show up in practice a lot
uh people are interested in maximal
clique enumeration
so give me every single clique that
can't be made bigger by adding a vertex
oh again coming back to one of my pet
hates
um several published tables of results
for
the quick enumeration problem are wrong
i have emailed the authors of some of
these papers
and have received replies like oh it
doesn't really matter we proved the
algorithm is correct
the implementation is in mind in detail
and
oh this is just a conference paper it
doesn't really matter
i i do get a bit upset by this
particularly since i had
a student implement one of these
algorithms and the student was
very upset for no matter what they did
they couldn't reproduce the
published solution counts on a standard
set of benchmark instances
partly this is due to vdmx file formats
in the ambiguity a lot of solvers don't
read any input files correctly but
so
the that does seem to be less interested
in making sure that solvers are actually
correct
for the quick enumeration problem which
is a bit disappointing
another common variant of a problem is
uh the maximum weight click problem
so vertices now have weights and rather
than trying to find the
biggest quick we're trying to find a
clique with the biggest sum of the
weights
and weighted quicksort was working
pretty much the same way but they
they use weighted colorings and similar
to get a bound
this this is quite a fun one to work on
there used to be a lack of good
benchmark incidents of this problem so
what people would do is they would
take the demax graphs and they would
give vertex v
the weight of v mod 200 plus one
so your weights would range from one to
two hundred
uh you would have vertices which were
two hundred times more important to go
into the clique found
some of the other vertices
you might think this is dodgy this is
indeed the case
i have a paper of some co-authors on
why this is bad why this really really
affects our
solar design and
collecting together a whole lot of
benchmark instances some literature and
producing some new ones
what we show is for example the
different way to distributions and
really affect how you should
implement your solving algorithms
we've also done prefogging for weighted
greek problems
something that surprised me is once
we've worked out how to do
uh prefogging using cutting points
for non-weighted
vertices so using the color band for
example
all you have to do is multiply by the
weight of a color class and you
immediately get
our cutting points proofs for all of the
weighted amounts of people have found
out in practice
this really surprised me i was expecting
a huge amount of work to
to do pre-flogging for weighted glitch
algorithms it turns out this isn't the
case
um so i am fully on board the
cutting point is awesome train at this
point
i would encourage you all to to start
using that
finally if again if you're looking for
something to work on that is fun there
are a lot of click relaxations
so there's a notion of a cake leak for
example where
vertices only have to be within distance
k of each other rather than being
adjacent
there is a related problem called the k
club problem
where vertices only have to be of a
distance k
but you're only allowed to use vertices
that are actually in the club when
you're calculating paths
algorithmically this is one of the most
horrific
problems i have ever seen being a
k-club is not a hereditary property
so uh you cannot incrementally build up
a club
it's it could be that you have a graph
which violates the club property
and you add a vertex and this makes the
club property hold again
if anybody is looking for a really fun
uh
algorithms project k-club is a good one
to work on
are also degree relaxations so i'll just
find me a set of vertices all of which
have very high degree
uh density relaxation so find me a
subgraph of density at least 0.9 and so
on
um there's a survey paper i've included
a reference to if you
want to work support on those uh some of
these relaxations are
really fun they've not had as much
research going to them so you can
you could for example set an interesting
student project and expect to
advance the state of the art of those
problems
i will take a break here if anybody is
interested then
i can go into a lot more detail about
various topics afterwards
okay so i've been monitoring the
chat so far i haven't seen anything but
at this point we're certainly
happy to take a few questions if you
want to ask in the chat or just
unmute and speak your mind and if you
happen to be an attendee rather than a
pen and this
panelist and cannot speak then just send
a message
and we'll give you speaker privileges
any questions for kieran from anyone
hi so
um for independent set which
is the the the same as clique for the
complement graph
i would have expected the hardest random
instances
to have density constant over n
so that the the independent aesthetics
is expected to be linear size
right which means that for clique i
would have a random graph i would expect
of the hardest instances
to be density one minus something over n
okay
yeah um so this this doesn't seem to be
oh what happens in practice i don't
think it's
um there's a limit to how big graphs we
can try this out on and what solves we
can use but it's
it looks like the hardest density
probably levels off at around 0.9
have you tried it meaning 150 is pretty
small
yeah the the difficulty is going beyond
about
200 vertices uh to this very high
variance on these instances uh
going beyond about 200 vertices would
really limit the size of the experiments
we can run
um i mean so going up by
say 50 vertices makes the problem
uh somewhere between 10 and 100 times
harder in practice of current solvers
so just saying it is harder to
you know to say like uh 1 minus 10
over n versus 0.9 is
is hard to distinguish when n is less
than 200.
yes oh
yeah the difficulty is i think we would
we probably need to run hundreds of
thousands of instances to get
an accurate measure here i have some
more plots in
part two of a talk which shows just how
high the variance is between runtimes
so there's a question from
massimo let's see could carry more
details about the difficulties
yeah so the obvious question is
is there a way that you can handle
uh connectedness just by encoding it
as encoding it as
say a graph property and in some ways
the answer is
is yes we're in np complete territory so
you know a reduction does exist it gives
you this but it's
um the
the reduction in question introduces a
huge number of additional vertices
and we also lose the optimization
property
so we can solve a decision problem this
way but we can't solve the optimization
problem in this way
so in practice it is easier to
modify a maximum quick algorithm so that
it knows that it is
solving a maximum common connected
subgraph problem
what you want to do is branch in such a
way that you're always maintaining the
connectedness constraints so any vertex
that you branch off
is adjacent to at least one of the
vertices that you've previously branched
on
in the original graphs
the difficulty of implementing this
inside a quick algorithm is that
cliques always really like to be able to
branch on arbitrary vertices
there's a very tight coupling between
the bound function and the branching
order
so if you want to change the branching
order you have to fundamentally change
how the bound function is written
this is doable it's it's just moderately
unpleasant
this does that answer your question
so how much when you're doing this color
bound
how much is it worth to get really good
coloring as opposed to
you know get something quick and dirty
and spend time solving is then can you
this this is a tricky question but it's
it does seem to be instance dependent
what seems to happen is on certain
classes of graph it's a really good idea
to have
a good bound function uh where
good depends upon what kind of graph
you're working on
um there are
um so for example the maximum common
subgraph graphs
there are ways for a naive greedy color
it can really misbehave
on these so a greedy coloring can
produce
uh so the example is find me for maximum
common subgraph between a graph with no
edges and a graph of one edge
a greedy coloring can produce a bound
which is one vertex
too large or one color too large and
additionally on every single recursive
call you make until you only have a
couple of vertices left it is one too
big
if you're in this case you really really
want to have a slightly different
slightly clever about function that
realizes what it's doing
in general we don't have a
characterization of
when bound functions when it's worth
being clever on a bound function
there are solvers that reuse coloring so
they don't produce a new coloring at
every stage in the search
instead they will take your chlorine
maybe they'll only produce new coloring
every five levels of the search tree
this allows them to put a lot more
effort into the coloring again this
this pays off on some instances it
doesn't pay off in other instances and
we have no idea why
so i had one more question if you wanted
to say anything about
learning and that somehow it's become
yeah so learning from conflicts didn't
seem
good yes um
i have i've never seen anything
be useful come out of this in quick
solvers this could just be a performance
thing it could be because you
you can't learn very much
it could be because it's always the the
bound function does
does what learning would do i haven't
even found a way of
framing the right question to ask to be
able to measure this
scientifically
this this also seems to be the case for
example subgraph isomorphism
so some graph isomorphism solvers are a
lot more a lot closer to constrained
programming or sound solvers
and you can take uh the sap learning
escapement you can put it into
a state of the arts and provide some
morphism solver
but the clauses you learn will almost
never fire
and i don't entirely understand why this
is the case
so i'm thinking if there are no more
questions then we'll take
a 10 minute break
and then uh so what will happen after
the way you'll give us a menu or you'll
just run
through yeah so do you want to give a
preview
you have a preview so i can i can go
into
lots more detail about random instances
i can explain why you branch from right
to left rather than
left to right
and i can go into a lot more detail on
how
proof working works in practice for
these algorithms
okay so there just before we break there
was apparently one question
on youtube fabio furini
are you aware of any click algorithm
using the theta number as a bonding ah
yes so the the theta function um
for people who don't know it's um
it's it is a graph property that is
always in between
the clique number and the coloring
number
and it can be computed in polynomial
time
so in theory this should be a really
really good bound function because
it's it's guaranteed to be at least as
good as carrying and probably a lot
better
the difficulty is uh what we say
can be computed in polynomial time are
as far as i'm aware this means can be
computed in polynomial time using some
very theoretical uh semi-definite
programming trickery
the last time i looked at this the only
graphs where people had actually been
able to
compute the theta number were
very small graphs and uh families of
perfect graphs which we could solve
trivially using a quicksilver anyway
the the difficulty seems to be
uh although the theta number is
theoretically in p we we don't have an
algorithm that we can
run on arbitrary graphs
or millions of times per second so it's
it doesn't seem to it doesn't seem to be
practical at this point
apparently more on youtube so there was
also this other question thanks for the
nice talk are you aware if there are
coloring problems providing
upper bounds for the clique relaxations
uh let's see
uh so k click for example
uh you can reduce uh
cakeway to quake and use the color bound
silvers
um effectively you're finding a distance
to coloring so
yes in that case uh k
club you could do the same
thing but it wouldn't necessarily be as
good about
i i think in in general for most of
these
um you can make coloring
work but it doesn't necessarily give you
as good a bound
which would be how i would answer that
question
you can either produce a coloring or you
can produce something that is inspired
by coloring
you just change the definition of when
things can go in two different color
classes and people do do this
how well it works in practice depends
upon exactly what the variant is
okay so then let's take a
10 minute break so we'll be back at like
i guess uh what is it
12 no yeah 12 minutes to the hour
then okay like
so
so i think it's starting to
get back there's been some discussion in
the chat while we were away
uh i don't know if we want to comment
briefly on this so that we get it also
on the recording i
don't think the chat is visible on the
recording
um there was one question that a
question regarding efficient algorithms
for computing the clique partition
number yeah so
i have not played with click partition
number at all
um i've i've had a quick look at
cluster editing which is kind of a
similar problem
which is um this year's pace challenge
problem
but i've i've not done very much on this
i'm afraid
then there's also a question whether uh
sat or pseudo boolean solvers could be
run on click problems
appropriately encoded and whether
anything you know have you ever seen
anything good coming out of learned
constraints yeah so i've
i've not tried to read the word
constraints
for the clique problem i
did do it for subgraph isomorphism
this was with peter stuckey
because as far as figuring out that um
so for example uh you might learn that
if vertex a gets mapped to vertex one
then something with this distance two
away
from a can't get mapped to something
that is distance two away from vertex
one which is an invariant but
subgraph isomorphism solve was already
used so
the learned clauses were almost figuring
this out sometimes
except that the learned clauses have a
huge number of
negative literals that don't that are
completely unnecessary
so they say if you map vertex a to
vertex one
and if then a list of 50
things say if this particular vertex
doesn't go here this particular vertex
doesn't go here
then this this vertex that is two away
from
uh vertex a cannot be mapped to
something that is
not limit distance to a vertex one
but i i couldn't figure out how to
how to get something useful after that
the the closest i got was trying to run
propagation
backwards so the issue is
you might make a lot of a lot of
branching decisions
and then no it might be for example the
first 10 for the 11th branching
decisions will the actually important
ones
and if you only propagated those three
branching decisions you would get a
really good conflict clause
but because you've done everything in
the middle somehow conflict analysis is
is getting very messy and it doesn't
realize it
i didn't find out a way of doing
something efficient with that
so how will you entertain us now
uh unless anybody wants to
uh request a particular or uh
order of events so we'll talk about
random instances first
and then uh depending upon how long that
takes
oh i could also talk a bit about
pre-fogging and why oh
pseudobully and proof hogging is is the
best thing anybody has ever invented
you wouldn't admit to being partially
biased there
possibly certain conflict of interest
yes
yep which might be shared by the
share of the session also but of course
i would be very excited to hear more
about that topic
um okay please go ahead i think i mean
i'm keeping track of the
chat i don't see any clear reactions so
i think uh
i'll just keep monitoring and please
you know for to all attend this shout
out any questions you might have we're
entering like the interactive part now
so yeah or the even more interactive
part hopefully
okay so um i'm guessing a lot of people
are familiar with the
phase transition in sat experiments
the the question is now for decision
problems or
we can generate a random graph with for
example 150 vertices and a random
a different random edge probabilities
and we can ask whether it contains
say a 20 vertex clique
this this plot shows what happens if
if you do this you're in a lot of
experiments so we
vary the edge probability along the
x-axis from
no edges to all the edges
obviously if we have all of the edges
we're looking at 150 vertex
graph we are definitely going to have a
20 vertex quick so we see
the yellow region on the right of a
graph everything is satisfiable in
radiumus
if we have no edges at all so we're on
the left hand side of a graph
then obviously there are no satisfiable
instances
and then in the middle we have this this
very specific
density this very sharp phase transition
from
none of the instances are satisfiable to
all of the instances are satisfiable
then if we look at how hard these
instances are for
a clique decision solver we see that
um the most the most difficult instances
correspond very closely to this this
point where
we're not really sure whether we're
satisfiable or not
so the graph is sufficiently sparse it's
trivially unsatisfiable
and if it's sufficiently dense and it's
trivially satisfiable
this is a commonly given intuition for
this
which is okay if you have low density
that means there are no occurrences of
the clique we're looking for
and we can very quickly show that we run
out of edges after we do a bit of
branching so these instances are easy
and if there's a high density that means
that there are lots of occurrences
so wherever we look it is easy to find
an occurrence
and if we expect there is probably just
one solution it's really hard to find it
if it exists and it's really hard to
rule it out if it doesn't
exist this this is the commonly given
plausible explanation so we're going to
look at this in a bit more detail and
we're going to look at optimization
problems as well but i will just say
that
this is this is completely wrong um
it turns out that uh the reason high
density
instances are easy to solve has nothing
to do with the number of occurrences
which is
which is kind of interesting
so i showed this plot earlier this was
what we used to know about
whether uh optimization instances for
cleat were
easy or hard and i really dislike this
these plots even though it was my boss
at the time who produced them
there are so many unanswered questions
if you look at them so which density is
hardest for the optimization problems
you can't really tell the plots on high
enough resolution does this change
depending upon the number of vertices
the algorithm used a random graph model
selected and so on
is it the same as the hardest density
for the decision problem if we can also
pick the decision number and if so
no what decision number do we pick you
can't tell any of these things of these
plots
so i decided to run up a very large
electricity bill
and do some really big experiments
so increa let's increase density in
steps of 0.001
so around one pixel per step in the
plots
let's do a hundred thousand samples of
every single
uh density that we pick
and you can do a back of the estimate
back of the envelope feasibility
estimate this will take about 18 years
to run
but i have access to a computer and
18 years to run is 150 000 hours
but when combined with the rest of the
experiments i wanted to run um
you can get a guess of okay we can do
something interesting with a million
core hours but it turns out that a
million core hours
now is something you can get just by
filling in a full there's no
formal grant application process or
anything
this is within nicely territory so
let's run up a massive electricity bill
let's use a
huge super computing facility and let's
produce some very smooth lines
i showed before when we start we'll keep
these pots now they're in such high
detail that we can see that there are
some
wiggles this
uh this light blue line is wavy and if
you zoom in enough you can see it is
wavy all the way along it's not just
towards very low densities it's just the
peaks of the wiggles get closer and
closer together
so conjecture what happens if we look at
the optimization problem in the decision
problem do they have something
similar to each other so here is the
optimization problem difficulty for
varying edge probabilities
and here is a single decision problem i
think this is the 20 decision problem
what we can see is okay maybe so
that's at this point here uh the
20 decision problem is a little bit
easier than the
optimization problem and we can start
putting some more
decision problems so the one two three
four etcetera decision problems
and we can put them all on if you look
closely now you can see that in some
sense the
wiggles we get from the different
decision problems
uh somehow seem to be connected to the
wiggles of a difficulty optimization
problem
this is maybe not that surprising
we can also plot some other things uh we
don't shrink the solver and measure how
long it takes we can measure
uh once we know what the optimal
solution is we can rerun the solver and
say you're allowed to stop as soon as
you found the optimal solution
we can also rerun the solver with it
initialized
to what the optimal solution is so we're
just saying go ahead and prove that
there is nothing bigger
so we we can only do this once we solve
the problem but it does tell us some
interesting things about how the solvers
are behaving
so looking at how long it takes just to
find an optimal solution but not to
prove its optimality now again we get a
line and the
wiggles are much more pronounced now
now it looks like finding a solution but
not proving optimality is a bit less
an order of magnitude
easier than the optimization problem
and looking at the proof of optimality
we see that the the proof of optimality
is nearly as difficult as the
optimization problem
but again it's wiggly you see the
the instances where finding a solution
is
hardest of the instances where proving
optimality is
easiest and so on and the reason the
total cost line seems to wiggle is
is basically because it's dominated by
the proof of optimality so whatever
proof of optimality does the
overall difficulty of the optimization
problem does
oh we can keep going
we can look just at problem instances
that have a particular solution size so
if i take for example just the instances
that have uh an optimal solution size
20.
we can plot them over here so this line
what i'm showing here uh this is
this is selecting just the instances
that happen to have an optimal solution
of 20.
severe occur in a relatively narrow
range of edge densities
darker colours on this line mean they're
more common so
down at the left hand side the right
hand side where we have light colours
these instances are very rare
uh this is also why the lines are all
over the place for sample size is very
small so v
we're taking an average of a small
number of runs
but it seems to be that instances
are instances
further to the left are easier than
typical so
if oh
let me get this the right way around um
so if we further to the left we're
having an
unusually large optimal solution
compared to what is expected and these
instances seem to be easier
and instances further to the right have
um an
unexpectedly small optimal solution
compared to what we're expecting
now these instances seem to be harder
and we can plot everything on in one
place
and again you see um
at any given point you can uh
you can end up on one of say five or six
different curves for any given density
and the difficulty of given problem
instances depends quite a lot about what
the optimal solution is
so there could be you know easily an
order of magnitude difference in
empirical complexity depending upon
whether you happen to have an
unexpectedly smaller and unexpectedly
large clique
and interestingly this behavior of uh
instances further writer harder
continues even when the average
difficulty is going down
this if you follow the conventional
explanation to its logical conclusion
you would not expect to see
we can also look at
what i'm calling optimal solution
frequency here so uh
picking a a given the solutions i have a
given size i think this is
again 20 version 20 vertex clicks
we see these occur with a den with
densities in between 0.7 and 0.8
and as the density increases the total
search effort
gets bigger and bigger
we can look at the relative frequency so
how often do
such instances appear and we see that
okay if the edge probability is 0.76
then
it is most common to see a 20 vertex
maximum click
and either side they are less common
we can also rewrite the solver again and
and say
okay i know that 20 is optimal tell me
how many
20 vertex cliques exist in this graph
now what we're seeing is for instance is
where 20 is the optimal solution
if we have a very low entry probability
there is only
one witness so there is only a single
solution uh so you might think okay
single solution really hard to find
and then as the density increases the
solution count becomes larger and larger
so
uh further towards the right uh if we
generate such an instance there are an
awful lot of 20 vertex clicks but no 21
vertex click but this is unusual
now we can plot the amount of search
effort that is taken to
find this 20 v find a 20 vertex clique
would not prove its optimality and what
you might expect is that
this would be a line just sloping
downwards you might expect to see
that because you might think okay the
more
solutions the more witnesses are the
easier it is to find one
what's actually happening is as the
number of witnesses increases
uh for a long time the difficulty of
finding such a witness
also increases so even though there are
more
optimal solutions so more things you
could find
actually finding one of these gets
harder not easier for a long time
the explanation here i'm not going to a
huge amount of detail but
um what's going on is it turns out these
songs are really not trying to
find maybe large creek at all
the correct way of phrasing what's going
on is that
uh a solver will try as hard as possible
to
throw away as much of a search base as
possible
[Music]
it will try to rule out portions of the
search base very
uh very aggressively even if this means
not finding a witness
so the the question that
determines how hard it is to find a
a particular witness is how many places
kind of do i have to rule out before i
am forced to find
a solution this is very different from
the
conventional over constraint programs
think that optimization algorithms work
this this happens even for very high
densities which again you
you might not expect because the
problems get easier if the density is
sufficiently high
we can look at the search order here oh
so we can search
and look at the total difficulty using
the uh the right to left ordering that
the
cleat solvers will use well we can look
at the total search ordering
using the anti-heuristics so iterating
from left to right
but what we see is the the
anti-heuristic
behaves much worse it's you know two
three orders of magnitude so
if they're denser sentences
so this this lights up with what we know
that uh iterating from right to left is
a good idea
a left or right is a bad idea
we can also look at the time it takes to
find a
an optimal solution but not prove it
again once we know what the optimal
solution is
looking at both the conventional
ordering and the anti-heuristic
uh what we're seeing is again finding
an optimal solution is more difficult
for the anti-heuristic except
in very low densities in some places
but here's something possibly
counter-intuitive
what i'm plotting here is what i call
first solution quality so just looking
at the
first clique for the algorithm points so
just let it run don't do any
backtracking and tell me okay what is
the first click you found
and i'm plotting how big this first
solution is
as a fraction of what we know the
optimal solution to be for a given
instance
and i'm looking at this using both the
default search ordering
and the anti-heuristic which is much
worse so
um searching backwards what we see is
searching backwards the red line on top
is actually finding better
solutions it is finding better first
solutions for searching in the good
order
even though it's worse overall
and we can plot this uh using
uh a slightly more advanced technique uh
so explain what this
this heat map shows uh we are looking at
uh problem instances where the solution
is
a 20 vertex clique
we are running a whole load of problem
instances
every time a solver finds
a a new incumbent so every time it finds
a new better solution
we're putting a point so a little human
number of recursive calls it took there
and then the heat map is plotting the
density of points at a given region with
darker colors meaning this is most
common
so what we're looking at is so
a typical trajectory is uh the
quicksolver will start off
finding say an incumbent with maybe
14 vertices as its first step
and then as time goes on say by
a hundred recursive calls it will be
finding maybe a 15
17 vertex incumbent uh up until
somewhere between let's say 10 to 3 and
10 for four recursive calls it will find
a 20 vertex incumbent and
finishing off uh and plotting the final
column
when it completes a proof of optimality
this is taking
just a bit below 10 to before recursive
calls typically
so this is using the the correct search
order heuristic
it's interesting to plot this using the
bad search order heuristic as well
here's what happens and i'll i'll go
backwards and forwards between the two
so oh i need a better pdf reader for
this
what we're seeing is if the
anti-heuristic starts off by finding
solutions of say 15 to 18 vertices as
opposed to
say 14 vertices a good heuristic does
but then it gets stuck and it takes
much much longer to improve the
incumbent after the first few steps
and eventually the proof of optimality
takes much longer and finding the last
few
cliques takes much longer
even though it performed better earlier
on what this is showing is if you're
designing search strategies there is
this fundamental trade-off between
anytime behavior versus proving
optimality but if you want to solve a
verb
find really good solutions quickly you
actually want to do the
opposite in search to what you're doing
if you're trying to prove optimality
if if you want to find good clicks
quickly you want to do a
greedy branching strategy where you want
to keep as much stuff as possible to
try to grow to try to give you room to
grow the clique as fast as possible
if you want to prove optimality you want
to throw away
as much as possible as quickly as you
can so that there is
less search space to explore even if
this means getting rid of optimal
optimal incumbents
and because the proof of optimality is
the
hardest part this is what dominates
you should be designing your algorithms
to be good at proofs of optimality
and completely forget about anytime
behavior
or possibly do something different to
get good at behavior as well
but there are a lot of open questions
about this this was just the first
one million core hours to run these
experiments um
i have not run maxsat's pseudo boolean
or map solvers on these instances
possibly on smaller graphs to see if
they do the same thing
no this would be something i'd be very
interested to do
um i hadn't when i ran these experiments
looked at what the state of the art of
max had a sudobu in solving was enough
to
figure out what experiments to run uh i
had not figured out how to run
commercial mip solvers on the
supercomputer setup
uh they have access to just varying or
licensing reasons
when i ran these experiments i had not
looked into much detail about the
uh open source mip solvers that i could
run
so i think this could be a really
interesting set of experiments to
run if somebody wants to join in on this
also interesting to look at the models
of randomness
but the main thing i learned from
running these is how much i
hate other people's solvers
[Music]
there's if if you're trying to run
a billion problem instances runs almost
on a billion problem instances
everything has to be
fully automatic fully reproducible fully
automated
the the number of bugs i found in other
people's coats it's always just
really occasionally producing rock
answers was quite worrying
also having to deal with for example how
people implement timeouts or don't
implement timeouts
it's really bad if people have a solver
that
allegedly has timeout code but will
sometimes leave a straight process
running when it finishes so this is a
good way to
run out of memory on the other system
it's really awkward if people solvers
will randomly write to
files on disks in particular situations
or if they occasionally print strange
things to
standard outputs one of the things i've
really been wanting to develop is a set
of
standards a standard document saying if
you are writing a solver
then these are the best practices you
should follow so that
people could run these huge experiments
without running into difficulties
you know so again that's something i'd
be interested in
collaborating on
are there any questions on this bit or
should i talk some more about
color ordering
okay
so remember i said that coloring gives a
bound
for clique solvers so if i can color a
graph using four colors
then there can't be a greater than four
vertex clique in there
and then what's always do in practice is
they write out vertices in this color
order so
uh write out all the vertices in the
first color first and the order of their
colored
and then the second color class and
whatever color and so on and then
iterate from right to left
and the conventional wisdom was that
vertices on the right were somehow
more likely to appear in a greek and
vertices on the left
and it turns out this isn't the case so
what's actually going on here
here is an alternative hypothesis an
alternative plausible explanation for
this behavior
so i'm going to claim that branching on
a color class is a bit like branching on
a variable
domain in constraint programming
so here we have a
domain for each a variable for each
color class with the values being
vertices plus null saying don't take
anything from this color class
okay in constraint programming we know
that branching on smallest domain first
is a good heuristic
so i'm going to claim that greedy
colorings tend to produce
larger color classes first so the first
color you use
will tend to have more vertices in it
than later colors
the reason being whenever you're
coloring a vertex you put it into the
first color class where it can fit
so i'm going to claim that greedy
colorings will be
biased towards first color class big
last color class
small and if this is the case then
branching from right to left is a bit
like doing a small estimate first
heuristic constraint programming
it's it's slightly different because
we're producing new colorings at every
different level of the search so in some
sense what our variables are
will change but in some sense branching
on the smallest color class
uh still resembles smallest domain first
therefore this is why right to left
coloring is a good idea
but i'm not going to stick with just a
plausible hypothesis here i'm going to
test this and run some experiments and
see whether it's actually true or not
so what can we do we can take
a clique algorithm we can
look at its coloring code and we can add
some statistics to
its coloring code and we can say
uh is it the case of
the statistical test is is it the case
that the
color classes you have produced are
ordered from
largest to smallest
and it turns out for a statistical test
for this um
i i'm not remembering the name of a
class of tests for one what we use is a
kendall tau measure which uh
what this does is it gives you the value
one if
you have uh biggest to smallest
it gives you the value minus one if you
have smallest to biggest
uh it tends to give you a value of zero
if the
um if the color classes are in no
particular order
so we can run an algorithm we can
measure every single color
it produces over a huge number of
instances and
we can plot whether or not
the color classes are actually produced
from largest to smallest
the plot on the screen shows
what we would see if
color classes were in no particular
order so if a greedy coloring produces
color classes
in a totally random order what we're
seeing
so dark colors means this is more common
on the very left hand side of the plot
so if we only produce a small number of
color classes
then the statistical test can only give
us zero minus one or one
but as we have lots of color classes we
see the dark region in the middle
so what this is saying is
um if the color classes are in a
completely random order
then uh most of them the uh
the kindletown measure will give us a
zero so we'll see this dark region
in the middle of the plot if color
classes were
completely sorted in perfect order what
we would see is this
so if we have a very small number of
color classes then
the measure will give us over zero or
one
if we have a large number of color
classes then we're going to see
that uh they are completely sorted by
size we'll always get one out of the
measure
now let's look at what actually happens
in practice what we see here is if we
measure
color classes in the order that we have
produced so uh
from a greedy coloring what you see
is the the darkest region of this plot
is here
somewhere between zero and one so what
this means is that
yes it is the case that greedy colorings
produce
approximately largest color class to
smallest color class
most of the time far from perfectly but
it is the case that
early color classes tend to be larger
than uh later color classes
so far so good but this doesn't tell us
that this has anything to do with
performance
so here's another thing we can do
we can run the algorithm
with the default ordering
or we could run the algorithm with color
classes actually sorted so you sort the
color classes
and rather than branching from right to
lefty branch from uh
smallest color class to largest color
class
what you see is the uh so we're looking
at a number of recursive calls
we see we're saving maybe 25 so we're
getting a 25
reduction in search based size
the line ever so slightly above
is a partial sort so we're saying okay
branch on any color class that has
just one value in it so branch on any
singleton color class first
and keep the rest of them in order the
reason is this is slightly more
efficient to
implement to practice but what we see
again is
um this is slightly worse than branching
on a fully sorted order
but much better for branching on a
default order
we could also plot uh branching on
shuffled card classes which would be
much much worse than any of us
so at this point what these experiments
show is that
it is the case that branching on
branching from right to left
approximately branch
approximately gives you a smallest
domain first heuristic
it is the case that branching on smaller
uh smaller color classes first gives you
improved performance so
a reduction in search based size
and the amount of reduction you gain in
the search base
but size increases the more that you
make uh
color classes sorted so i think
empirically this is
uh much better evidence
for the uh for the hypothesis that it's
to do with smallest domain first
for the hypothesis that it is finding uh
strong incumbents faster
i don't know if this explains everything
but so i think it is a bit of an
improvement
um unfortunately you practice this has a
very small impact on runtime uh most of
the search based
savings you gain uh go away because of
the complexity of doing your sort
this gets you maybe a 10 improvement on
runtimes it's
it's not a big deal
and i found it was very hard to publish
this it was
very hard to sell hey we are
understanding why this algorithm works
uh when we're not really using that
that knowledge to make the algorithm an
awful lot faster well
the general query was yes but this only
gives you 10 percent why should we care
whether or not this is true or not um
this this work was what really pushed me
towards the
constraint programming community to be
honest um
the i had had this paper rejected from a
couple of empirical algorithmics
conferences
or saying i have no idea what you're
doing or why you're doing this go away
whereas i got three very positive
reviews from cp on this so this is
uh this is why i now send empirical
algorithmics papers to cp rather than
say
issa or sca
i seem to be in a minority on this but
it was a lovely paper from 1995 by john
hooker
in the journal of heuristics volume 1
issue 1 titled
testing heuristics we have it all wrong
where
he argues for a scientific approach
to algorithm evaluation so he wants to
see an end to
what he calls horse races so this
algorithm is faster than this algorithm
therefore this algorithm is better
and uh he wants us to adopt a much more
scientific approach to
testing and understanding algebra
behavior i think this is a lovely paper
unfortunately there doesn't seem to have
been much progress since that paper is
written
actually persuading anyone else this is
a good idea
but that's what i have to say about
search orderings
again if if there are questions
please interrupt plea please ask
if not says is anybody interested in
is anybody interested in proof logging
propaganda
oh i can
uh i i can talk about why everybody
should be writing
proof fogging and all my solvers if that
is of interest
okay i'll keep going and please do run
off if you have
somewhere interesting to me
so certifying solvers the idea is
alongside an answer you produce a proof
that's uh
the uh the answer that you gave is
correct so um
what a certifying solver is one that
provides a way of carrying
guaranteeing that uh an output is
correct you're not you're not guaranteed
the silver is correct but you are
guaranteeing somehow i have i have
solved this problem in a legitimate way
here is a verifiable proof of what i've
done is definitely correct
the idea is these certificates have to
be checked independently using a
solar independent tool that is very very
simple that is much easier to
trust for the solver itself
i was i got interested in
um certifying solvers for two reasons
one was
in uh seeing the number of really
subtle bugs and small numbers of
instances that clique solvers were
producing and
uh getting very
paranoid that my own solvers would be
buggy particularly for subgraph
isomorphism
so i have the state of the arts of
graphisomorphism solver
that can solve a lot of instances that
nobody else can solve
but do i trust my own code
not really uh am i 100 confident that
every algorithm i've ever published is
definitely correct
probably not i suspected at least one of
my published algorithms at one point has
had a bug in it
um and also through
conversations of jakob who convinced me
that proof vlogging was actually
practical and viable
for these kinds of algorithms
so the sac community we have cnn
formulae we have
proof synth you know rook d rat l rap
grit etc
lots of proof almost doing interesting
things
but as far as i can see if a sat solver
does cardinality reasoning for example
then
most people turn proof fogging off it
doesn't seem to be
widely used yet
this is a bit of a problem because a lot
of graphs always do cardinality
reasoning and color class reasoning and
so on
and uh we need if we're pushing for
proof logging for everybody we need
something
practical we need an approach that's
not just that clever people can use but
that solver authors like me
and even more or not we need uh
solver offers like my students you know
to be able to use it so what i'm
suggesting here is
pseudo boolean formally instead of
proofs using reverse unit propagation
and cutting planes now i'll give a brief
walkthrough of
why this seems to work in practice
i'll just show you this in action so we
can take the state of the art in cliques
of
clique solving we can run it on one of
the dimex instances
uh we're seeing this is taking um
a hundred thousand recursive calls and
it's doing it in 175 milliseconds
this this does mean it's producing a
hundred thousand
different colorings for the band
function as well
we can tell it to write a proof to disk
uh
which it does again uh using the system
we have it does run
quite a lot slower these experiments are
being run on the machine with
uh spinning rust discs it turns out
nearly all of the
overheads from this approach we're
discussing are just the cost of getting
something out of disk
i have recently bought an upgrade for a
cluster to put in some solid state
drives but
um can't actually get in the building to
install these yet so
um be interesting to see how much that
number improves
and in practice okay so we're producing
a
500 megabyte proof log
for this uh hundred thousand recursive
call
uh problem instance and we can verify
this
unfortunately um so this is using
stefan's
verifier on verify
which is now faster than when i run
these experiments
at the time it was taking right about
400 seconds to
verify this proof hog so this is
this is quite a lot of overhead i'm
trying to be very upfront about this
but it does work in practice
so the techniques that we introduce uh
this is a cp 20
20 20 paper if you're after more details
uh our general this is not limited to
one particular solver
as as far as i know we now know how to
do proof logging for every single
maximum quick algorithm that has ever
been proposed
the implementation effort is very small
it can even speed up solar development
with the right proof login format we can
express combinatorial and
graph arguments even if the proof format
doesn't know what a graph is so cutting
points doesn't know what a graph is
this does not stop us from reasoning
about colorings or in simplify
symmorphism algorithms about vertex
degrees and so on
and in some sense the proofs we write
are the same length as
the amount of work done by the solver
i am not the right person to talk to
about
what the same length as here means but
it does mean we're not for example
getting
uh an exponential blow up in writing out
the proof
and another thing i'll discuss very
briefly is that problem reformulations
that occur a lot in cp so um
for example solving maximum common
subgraph using maximum greek that can
also be pre-flogged
but my very bold claim is that it is
time for competition organizers to start
requiring pre-fogging supports
and say this happens in set it doesn't
happen anywhere else
it'll be nice to see for example the
pace challenge at least introduce a
pre-vlogging track
so what's the certifying pro process
we've
had a lot of talks about this so i'll
just go over this quickly
we express a problem in pseudo-boolean
form
so zero one variables integer linear
inequalities
and an objective function
we are assuming that you know somehow
how to express clique
in a pseudo boolean format in in a
standard way
so this this part is not in any way
formally verified
then we write this out in the standard
suitable lead formula the vopp
file format and we provide a proof log
for this opv file which
uh if we're doing an unset decision
instance we demonstrate we can prove
that zero is greater or equal to one
we also want to be able to log satisfy
voltage decision instances enumeration
and branch and bound optimization just
so we can really reflect
exactly what the solvers are doing
and we give this opp file under proof
vlog to verify and it says
yes everything is fine or no you have a
problem you've cheated
so the pseudo boolean encoding is is
straightforward
we are we have a zero-odd variable for
every vertex
we're looking to minimize the
negations so we're looking to maximize
the number of vertices that we select
and for every non-edge we say that you
can't take
you can't set both variables to one
uh just very briefly uh this is what the
search tree looks like for a quick solo
this algorithm
uh i'll i'll go over this but
we start we're branching at the top
level on vertices say 12 11
then eight then at the second level
we're branching on vertex
seven so we have a seven and twelve and
we know that only vertices six and one
are left
and we find an incumbent and so on
now proof to describing the search tree
in the uh very pv
format uh looks something like this so
we have a header
we start off with f command that says
okay
read in the vopb model
the o line says i have found a new
incumbent we do this twice we have one
here so okay i have found the x7x9x12 is
a clique
and i found x2 x5 x8 is a click
and then every time we backtrack in the
quicksolver we output one of these
uh reverse unit propagation steps so
this is saying i am backtracking from
having branched on x12 and x7
i am backtracking from having branched
on x12 i am backtracking from private
branched on x11 x10
then i'm just x11 been on x8x5
x8 and finally i'm backtracking from top
level
and i am claiming this is a complete
proof
so this uses something called reverse
unit propagation
um this effectively we
we take a constraint uh we negate that
constraint we add it to the model and we
assert that this unit propagates too
unsatisfiable so
um this tells us that okay obviously it
is safe to learn this new constraint
this is really nice for solver authors
because for example we don't have to
justify adjacency reasoning um
we are we only need to output backtracks
we don't need to say
hey i branched on vertex 6 therefore
vertex 7 cannot be included in the
glutam we don't need to do any about
the problem is the bound function
so remember i said we can use coloring
color classes describe at most one
constraints in pseudo-boolean terms
but this does not follow from reverse
unit propagation so we need to provide
the proof verifier some assistance here
uh cutting points proofs again i'll i'll
be quick on this since there have been
plenty of talks on this already we can
add constraints we can multiply
constraints we can divide constraints
and it turns out once you can do this
you can manually recover at most one
constraints for any color class
um in space uh proportional to number of
constraints that describe that color
class so again this is a very efficient
process
what this looks like in practice inside
of proof vlog um
so here star means comment we're trying
to derive an atmosphere one constraint
p uh if you've seen stefan's talks
you'll you'll notice his reverse poetry
polish notation we add together some
constraints
uh the text i've written in pink would
just be numbers
i'm just using text labels to make this
easier to read
we add some things we multiply some
things we divide some
things uh and we end up recovering the
atmosphere constraints uh i'll
i'll not go into detail of how this
works but the the important thing here
is
uh for example here where we have three
color classes
or nine vertices and the amount of space
needed uh in some sense only uses
um it only uses a number of
uh non-edge constraints are involved in
these core classes and it uses each
knowledge constraint at most once so
this is
uh a compact proof
so we have this implemented inside the
glycolysis of graph solver
uh 59 of the 80 instances can be solved
in under a thousand seconds
just using the silver out of the box
uh for 57 of these 59 instances we can
produce brewfox fever2 reached a
terabyte of disk space which is
all i have at the moment the the beans
slow down frog proof fogging is a factor
of 80.
this is an awful lot higher than we see
in south solvers
the difficulty is um
a clique solver can produce a complete
graph coloring
in a millisecond or considerably less
than a millisecond
so just writing this out to disk just
writing out what this coloring is is
already approaching the
the limitations of hard disk write
speeds
verification is about a further factor
of tens to lower
again very pb does not have access to
the super fast
bit set representation that
tweaks always use internally in some
sense we can't expect
a a verify that doesn't really
intimately know about graph data
structures to run as fast as a graph
solver does
but it this does mean that we can solve
these as we can at least verify
medium-sized instances
in practice given enough time
the important thing for me is see the
implementation effort of doing this
this uh this required one master's
student
basically a good master's student but
one master's student
a a six month dissertation project
to implement uh he came in knowing
nothing about clique algorithms and
nothing about proof vlogging
and came out having produced a profile
game clique algorithm
but more importantly once you've done
one quicksilver the rest are easy so if
you want to
put proof logging into uh any of the
quick solver we've
explained how to do it so it is much
easier now
we did the same for enumeration there
are contradictory results for graphs in
the literature
proofing is dead easy the
implementation effort for somebody who
had implemented
a maximum clique enumeration algorithm
was uh
one day of work for somebody who had
never done proofrocking before
and again we can run this on standard
benchmark graphs and know what their
results
know which results are actually correct
and which aren't
maximum weight click uh this
this is one of the things that really
convinced me that um
cutting planes is great for silver
authors
it turns out that everything we know for
unweighted clique is exactly the same
and if you want to generate
weighted greek bounds all you need to do
is multiply by the weight of a color
glass
this took a phd student
one afternoon to implement after he'd
seen a 20 minute talk i gave on how to
do it for greek algorithms
this is from never having done proof
vlogging before
max from common subgraph i click i'll
skip the details but we can encode
the reduction from maximum common
subgraph
to clique using cutting points so you
can feed
in uh a maximum combination graph
problem
expressed using a pseudo-boolean model
of a maximum common subgraph
problem that talks about partial
mappings
just using cutting points we can derive
everything you need to turn this into a
quick model
you can run the clique solver with
proofworking without it knowing that it
is working on a maximum common subgraph
problem
or produce a valid cursing points proof
of the cleat problem uh and everything
just works
this even works of a maximum common uh
connected sort of graph problem again
the uh a proof of geek leak solver does
not need to know
that it is working uh on a pseudo
boolean bottle for a maximum profits of
graph problem
i think this is really interesting
particularly thick and straight
programming when we do a lot of this
reformulation
this this one i implemented i
re-implemented the maximum common
connected subgraph five click algorithm
uh took an under a day uh the
verification caught a stupid bug in the
implementation that i made that i had
missed when testing this
so i would claim that implementing this
algorithm
with proof vlogging and getting it
correct was
less effort than implementing this
algorithm without pre-vlogging
oh i think
and i think this implementation effort
is really important if we want proof
vlogging to take over the world
we need this to be easy enough that it
can be given to say a master's student
to
implement
we need proofrocking to speed up
development of solvers rather than
rather be something that you put it on
and put a lot of effort in to slow it
down
lifting anything we can do to make proof
logging easier to use is
is really a worthwhile investment here
the other key point is we need to write
proofworking format so that
the proofs are simple so we can trust
the verifiers but at the same time still
efficient and we need
something like reverse unit propagation
so that's um
solver authors don't have to keep track
of everything they do and right at every
single step in excruciating detail
or they won't do it
so yeah i would like to see proof
logging as standard
not necessarily on for every single
instance sold every single time because
of the overheads but
i think we need something that is usable
in practice at least for medium-sized
instances
and that we need to um really start
persuading everybody to
adopt this if it's all possible
and i will stop there thank you
thank you here so
questions from the audience
in the chat or if you just wish to speak
let me know for for people who are only
attendees who might need speaking
privileges
just say the word oh marine i will allow
you to
talk i think
you should be able to speak now can you
hear me yes
yes ah good great uh thanks for the
wonderful talk i really liked it
so i also really um like how you
try to understand things and these great
plots
but let me have a few questions
regarding the proof vlogging
so yeah i was just wondering how much
so
[Music]
for example did you also try with for
example um
binary formats because when i saw that
you have one terabyte proofs right
it would suggest that a binary format
might be quite useful
for the things you're doing yes so i
suspect that
through a combination of of binary
formats um
not using the c plus plus standard
library etc to happen things
uh we might be able to get a factor of
10
or performance improvement out of this
the back of the envelope calculation uh
the difficulty being
it would be a lot more source code um i
think this is
so i think binary yeah some form of
heavily optimized binary proof will be
important for
uh pushing proof fogging to be used on
these really big instances
um the difficulty is i'm
also trying to convince people that this
is something
easy enough that they can make their
students do it so
this is i think the level we need for
world domination
oh it's
so i think that that it is possible also
if you look at
for the the binary format sometimes you
you actually
you write just a 20 line procedure that
kind of
converts everything from ascii to binary
and yeah
the same thing in your checker i don't
think it
does really need so and and those 20
lines you can just reuse in every solver
right it's just
okay so i think it there there might not
be too much overhead
yeah i mean it's it's definitely worth
looking at it's
i definitely think long term you know
figuring out the bottle head the the
bottleneck would be really interesting
um yeah i will happy to to talk about
you in
more detail yeah another question i had
is
are you able to kind of assess the
quality of the proofs
for example i think one of the nice
things we had we have in sutter is that
you
do this backwards checking and sometimes
see that only
one percent of of the generated clause
was actually
useful oh yeah so as
as far as i know we don't have this
implemented for
our cutting points proofs yet so i know
so stefan is here and and may want to
jump in on this possibly
but so i i suspect that this is
def and will be implementing at some
point
[Music]
yeah so stefan please
[Music]
um
actually
okay maybe another question one where
uh i mean i think in principle it's not
it
like um it's you can still look at the
proof and like
do exactly the same kind of trimming
there's nothing like
fundamentally uh
no it's just that it has to be done
i guess because i think one of the nice
thing is that if you if you have
something
like that you can see how how well the
algorithm is working right
yeah definitely yeah yeah yeah i mean
i suspect maybe not for clique but for
subgraph isomorphism
my my gut feeling is there will be
much much shorter proofs than what
solvers are actually finding
but hopefully these proofs will be
almost you know structural they'll be
saying you know this
this particular shape can only occur in
these two places and then it'll be very
easy to see that's
um you know this
this very quickly leads to an unsound
proof
but i i mean i would definitely be
interested in seeing what we can what we
can get out of these proofs beyond just
saying yes the solver is correct
no cool all right again can you hear it
oh yeah yeah yeah i can hear it
it's much better much much better yeah
um
okay so uh regarding the reverse
checking um
this is something i have somewhere down
my list um the problem
is that um you can't really reverse
check the
polish notation rules because they are
kind of
they don't tell you what the result is
um
so we would slightly need to change the
format to always provide the result of
each step
um so that you can then do the reverse
checking
um and regarding binary formats i think
is also like a very
like interesting point to look into and
i would really like to understand like
how much this can gain you um i guess
alternatively one could also try to
compress the proofs on the fly from the
text format i'm not sure
how like this would take in times of
time or how much this saves but i guess
there's a lot of things that we could
do there yeah i
did actually implement on the on the fly
compression but i made the mistake of
using the
um the boost bzip2
stream which
turns out to be um sufficiently slow for
everything you get back
from io you lose just because um
it is really not an efficient
implementation
you should use some very lightweight
thing yeah
yeah so
there's a question two questions in the
chat so from from massimo is asking
proof logging may allow unsound
heuristics that
may work well sometimes has it ever been
tried
so i guess i guess what you're
suggesting is um
do something unsound and then check
whether you actually produced a valid
proof and if you have then you don't
need to go any further
um i think the tricky thing from
incorporating this inside the
solver would be um
that the graph solvers for example uh
don't know anything about cutting points
they
all they're doing is following a
template to dump out
proof survey nova okay when you
backtrack you output this when you
do a coloring you do this when you do
this kind of reasoning you do this
they they don't know enough to check the
work
that they're doing themselves they don't
know what cutting point is they don't
know from suitably in reasoning
but it's this is this what you're
getting at
uh well i'm uh sort of because i think
that uh maybe
in your algorithm you can have an
unsound heuristic
that may be inside the software you may
think
or you may somehow deduce that
uh end up uh doing the correct
computation
but as a user of the solver that knows
that you are using gun sound heuristics
the fact that you are somehow logging
the proof
when you use such unsound heuristic can
be reassuring to me
to some extent even even more than
the usual algorithm right
does it make sense
i'm not sure
i would maybe say that i think the
problem might be in the opposite
direction right i mean
the the proof logging would rather like
the example that kieran had that you
would detect
like errors that you never see because
your your solver is taking some subtle
shortcut
which like doesn't actually affect the
final result
so it's okay except that when you switch
proof logging
on then this subtle shortcut is like all
over the place and the
proof checker just vomits on your proof
although the end result is correct
yeah so for example for for one of the
buggy greeks always you would
you would see errors and so for an error
to
for it to produce a wrong answer the
condition is something like
you have to have a single unique maximum
clique that has to include
the right most vertex that it branches
on at a particular stage in the search
there's an off by one error in a full
loop
that is the only way it will it will
output a wrong answer
but in terms of output to getting
correct proof it's really obvious what
it's doing because
it is it is missing uh one
propagate it's missing cutting off one
bit of the search tree at every level of
the search
so as soon as you put this into a proof
checker it will it will tell you in a
fairly obvious way that oh
hey this this for loop isn't complete
this this set of branching is
is not complete even though the solver
nearly always produces the right answer
arbin is asking do you have certified
proof checkers
uh again i think this is the staffer
not not yet but i guess we hope that
we will have them at some point i mean
there's
fundamentally i don't see a reason why
this should be much harder to get a
certified verifier
than for say the pac format or the red
but i guess it's work that needs to be
done and right now we are like more
focusing on getting everything fast and
maybe even add some more features so it
might still take some time
to have a verified verifier
yeah i mean i i think the the main thing
here is
the quest for world domination now
number one on the list is
is making this easy for solver authors
and number two is making it perform well
enough
it's usable in practice on medium size
instances
i think even even an uncertified proof
checker is
all so much better than anything we have
currently that
well it's it's going to catch you know
99 of the silver bugs
okay so it's getting late any final
questions before we
call it the day at least here in europe
or just checking did i miss anything in
the chat
or if so please shout out
i don't see anything
so then i think that we will
[Music]
thank kiran again
so what's happening now is so next
tuesday we'll have supratik chakraborty
talking about knowledge compilation for
boolean
functional synthesis and then
in the two weeks after that we're going
even further beyond
sat into uh so on march 30th
ambrose gleichner is going to talk about
mixed integer programming solving exact
midsoling
and then on april 6 thorsten schaub is
giving us a tutorial on answers at
programming and i think the rest of the
schedule would be
also on the simon's webpages but uh this
is what we have for today thanks again
kieran
thanks everybody for attending